c'est fait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un beau match à l'éviction de la nuit
votez votez
[Rires]
[Musique]
et janot
proche de la base on prête et pas assez
près encore voilà c'est dommage c'est
pas loin mais c'est dommage
aline hôpital
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
soumettez à merde attend les bars tiacoh
dans la gare abbaoui benoît cerexhe
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
et le koopa fr de bouffan n'allait pas
bouger longtemps voire pas du tout voilà
[Musique]
voilà
voyons voir sympa ok on y va toi tu vas
l'attaqué et à tulle a valu à coluche
gallet attaquer attaquer attention tu
attaque de la poule a - [ __ ] oui je
suis là tu dans la joie la corpo vidé
mais non mais vous savez je vais prendre
ça pour moi sommes dangereux c'est
toujours
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]